the real product market fit yes this was
a good one not that the other ones
aren't great I often talk to founders
who believe they've found product market
fit when they haven't this is a huge
problem because they start hiring people
increasing burn and optimizing their
product before they've actually
discovered what needs to be built I'm
writing this post to help you understand
when you've really found product market
fit to start read mark and driessen's on
product market fit for startups has been
the single most influential posts for me
as an entrepreneur and was the first and
it was the first time I ever read the
term here's how he defines the term the
customers are buying the product just as
fast as you can make it or use the usage
is growing just as fast as you can add
more servers money from customers is
piling up in your company checking
account you're hiring sales and customer
support staff as fast as you can
so why do most people think they're
there when they're not one it's
intellectually convenient - I think that
a lot of founders are really excited at
the prospect of company building uh-huh
and they think that company building is
what creates success and by company
building I mean like hiring employees
and having great culture and you know
getting an office and having management
and so on and so forth and they are not
real with themselves that like the real
challenge is to solve the problem yeah
and the company building happens for the
most part after you figure out how to
solve the problem not before I hear this
term product market fit so often and I
have to tell you like 98 percent of the
time is use incorrectly and like what's
so frustrating is that like people must
act like it's an undefined or like
flexibly defined term and it's like
totally not it's like saying that like
oh yeah like green blue yellow
we could call of those orange like it's
okay like we're just calm orange it's
different for every company yeah yeah
exactly it's like it's your
interpretation of what it's like no ah
this is like that's not the case like
this is a defined term viously make up
another term if you want to mean
something else so I think the most
common way it's mistaken is like it's
weird because it sounds
so close but it's not it's I built the
thing that customers want Brett and like
what's hilarious is like product market
fit is what happens after you built the
things that customers want it turns out
the only way you know you've built them
the customers want is because they're
using it in an explosive and destructive
way and like people want to separate
these two concepts it's like so amazing
it's like so like you can see
intellectually why it's just so much
easier to be able to look at your thing
and say this is what customers want
right and not have to really have any
customers oh yeah totally it's easier to
say that and so man people really just
want to separate those two things out
and it's like if you are not getting
explosive usage you do not have what
customers want um or there aren't that
many customers in which case you don't
have a big business know and so I think
that the awful reality is like the vast
majority of founders the vast majority
of YC founders even never find product
market fit ever I argue that like more
acquisitions than you might know are of
companies that did not find product
market fit
once you find product market fit I
almost say it's like it's your company
to [ __ ] up like it's almost like this is
gonna work unless you screw it up
whereas like pre product market fit
there's all this stuff you need to do to
even see if there can be something there
and you really don't know post product
market fit it's like if you execute you
get there pre product market fit you
guys do great I didn't never have
anything and moreover you can still have
customers you can solve growth if you're
pre proud yes yes yes yes it's not like
when I go from zero customers to one
customer I'm not hypnotic market like I
think that mark does a good job of
defining it because it's experiential
right I think if you tried to define it
any other way people would find
loopholes I mean they clearly have
already found loopholes but like yeah
it's like is the growth killing you like
if I were to extract what the meaning of
this sentence like is that growth almost
killing you yeah and is it profitable
like people always want to forget the
second one right like money
is piling up in the chicken cause by
definition profit yeah
like literally there are so many
companies who are like the growth is
killing us right and I'm like Oh show me
explain and they're scaling negative
margins exactly they're saying hey Craig
how about you pay 75 cents and I give
you $1 worth of value yeah make that
trade 17 times an hour I love that where
it's like they figure it out before you
cuz you're just burning VC money or your
own money yes the customer the customers
a nose for those types of diesel because
if you have the problem like you really
understand the value of the solution so
um what's funny to me is that you know
oftentimes founders will want to try to
reduce this like the quote I get this
question so often it's like should i
optimize for growth should i optimize
for retention or should i optimize for
profitability and my answer is always
the same
yes like what makes you think that
building a successful company is a
single variable problem but how could
that be the case it's clearly not the
case especially in the venture paradigm
yes yes yes for for a tech startup yes
it's clearly not the case like there's
clearly multiple variables here and you
know one of the things we try to taught
people we often if you're charging your
customer we try to talk to you about
revenue yeah and the reason why is that
like in many cases like revenue that you
keep is as close as we can get to a
single metric but like even that is not
perfect like you really want to know
like what's your what percentage of
revenue are you losing every month you
really want to know like how much does
it cost you to get that revenue like you
really want to know like how satisfied
your customers like like you need to
know those other stats to really know
and so yeah probably market fit like I
wish more comfortable site like I talked
about pre product market fit as just
being in the suck it's just like you
just in the river
crap and you're not enjoying your life
like and unfortunately I think that you
you every startup I almost imagine this
isn't the case but I almost imagine that
there's like a predetermined amount of
time you have to live there until you
figure out how to get out and like a lot
of founders just want to cheat and like
a lot of founders just like I want to
get out by cheating like I just want to
pretend like I'm not in here and like
build a nice house or I just want to
like do something as we've done
profitable it so I can tend to be out of
here and it's just like you you can't
pretend your way out of product market
failure does not work you have to be
comfortable you have to be so passionate
about the people you're working with and
or the problem that you're solving that
you are comfortable failing at it for a
while did you guys hit it at Socialcam
absolutely not so here's a perfect
example Socialcam over the course of
four months got 16 million downloads got
one-eighth of every single person on
Facebook to watch at least one video on
our platform over the course of three to
four months wouldn't that be like almost
the definition of potted murder if it we
certainly were dying in the traffic we
shut off like half the half the world
did not couldn't use the product cuz we
were like we can't do it absolutely not
for our product one we had no
monetization no probably probably could
have figure out monetization at that
point no monetization yeah um
to more importantly we had horrible
retention absolutely horrible retention
like if you came and downloaded the app
the chances that you were using that app
ten days later was basically zero if you
watched a video the chances that you'd
watch it five more videos that week very
low and like it was interesting because
it was like we had an exit yeah we had
tons of growth we for a while we're top
5 in the App Store
yet not product market fit yeah I'd even
argue I mean if you look back at Justin
TV right Justin TV by let's say 2000 and
let's think 10
she started 2006 by 2010 make sure I
have this dates right I think that's
correct yeah we made 8 million dollars
in revenue mm-hmm 1 million in profit
with approximately 30 million monthly
viewers on the product and we were not a
product market fit right yeah and so
it's slay yeah this it like it is hard
like and and the reason why and in it
for the Dustin TV case was that we
didn't have a repeatable engine to
create growth like that 300 million
monthly uniques we couldn't make that
number go up and then the second thing
was that unfortunately we were we had
tons of a copper and content on the site
yeah and so it wasn't we weren't able to
reliably monetize that over time right
and so it's like it's funny because I
can't imagine how many pitches that I
gave to trying to present that as a good
business when like in my heart I knew it
wasn't a good business yeah and I mean
like and like it wasn't until we
actually found twitch and found gamers
to actually find something that had this
like repeatable machine that both spit
out more users and more money and
retention and like what was so
interesting is that like we'd solved all
the technology problems at justin.tv
well clearly the market does not care
what you have behind the hood no no no
no like we had all the live video
streaming chat we have everything like
now like that was I mean let's be clear
necessary but not sufficient but we
never could have done it without that
stuff but it was not sufficient yeah at
all and like man what that take that
took it took six years for us to have a
hint that that's what the customer base
was right because then like the the suck
period with twitch as game streaming how
long did that go for before not fairly
not very long
oh no why it was interesting it didn't
go for very long because everything else
was already the table was set you're
kind of in place yeah we had people we
had all the
technology we needed we had money
because we were running profitably so
like it was all like like all of the the
table was set and then BAM the food
arrived like everyone was seated ever
the table was set band the food arrived
the meal happened like we were waiting
at the table for like Steven at but like
if you started twitch in 2006 probably
wouldn't worked you don't know I don't
think it would have worked in 2006 I
think looking back you silly little
things matter one of them who was
webcams
yeah like webcams went from being
something you had to buy extra to
something that were built into every
laptop like and it was like little
things like that can change things I
think that though had we been talking to
our users more we could have gotten
there sooner look I think we could have
gotten there by like 2008-2009 but you
know yeah we didn't die that was yeah
didn't die I have another shot it's a
big take away yeah yeah which is kind of
a separate thing probably separate I say
but like learning when you should have
quit maybe like some people do hold onto
things so new hold on things it's funny
like I see a two ways some people hold
onto things on the flip side though man
there are still some companies who like
some companies take a long time yeah
there are some peers of ours who like
now are really doing well but just took
even longer than we did and so man there
is a like if you're willing to put in
the time and grind it out like every
year you don't not die like like your
chances of being successful go up yeah
and then some companies sell too early
and they could have been so cool and
then they die within big companies yeah
let's Tebow trying to get paid that
happens too
you